dieser tisch ist längst zum sinnbild
geworden für die differenzen und den
abstand den ost und west zueinander
eingenommen haben wladimir putin
empfängt olaf scholz
bei der pressekonferenz macht sich
hoffnung breit dass sich ein fenster
öffnet für den frieden doch die
positionen bleiben die bekannten
präsident putin wird es nochmal krieg
gegen in europa gagne
natürlich nicht genau deshalb haben wir
auch einen vorschlag unterbreitet für
einen verhandlungsprozess an dessen ende
es eine vereinbarung über die sicherheit
aller geben muss einschließlich unseres
landes
es ist unsere verdammte pflicht und
aufgabe als staats und regierungschefs
zu verhindern dass es in europa zu einer
kriegerischen eskalation kommt
dabei ist krieg nach wie vor möglich an
der grenze zur ukraine lässt moskau seit
monaten die muskeln spielen putin sieht
sich in die ecke gedrängt erklärt die
nato zwinge ihn zur verteidigung weil
das bündnis zusagen gebrochen habe seit
jahren behauptete dass du immer keinen
zentimeter weiter nach osten hieß es in
den 90er jahren und jetzt sie haben
betrogen sie haben uns geradezu dreist
belogen nadu lee rotem nagellack
so fing alles an
1989 fall der berliner mauer der gesamte
ostblock wird in der folge zusammen
brechen und ein mann zur schlüsselfigur
brd außenminister genscher schreibt
geschichte wie hier in prag vor massen
geflüchtet hat ddr bürger
[Applaus]
ja
1990 verhandelte er mit gorbatschow
sowjetunion die bedingungen der
deutschen einheit es geht auch um die
zukunft deutschlands in der nato zu
besuch bei us außenminister james baker
in washington mark genscher ein
weitreichendes zugeständnis
wir waren uns einig dass nicht die
absicht besteht das radio verteidigungs
gebiet auszudehnen nach osten das geht
übrigens nicht nur in bezug auf die ddr
die wir da nicht einverleiben wollen
sondern das gilt ganz generell
rolf nikel war damals als junger
diplomat bei den verhandlungen dabei wie
beurteilt er heute was genscher damals
sagte
zum einen ist natürlich auch der
sowjetunion klar gewesen dass der
deutsche außenminister weder für die
gesamte bundesregierung sprechen kann
noch dass er für die nato als ganze
sprechen kann zum zweiten war es
natürlich auch damals so dass die
sowjetunion ja wirtschaftlich
außerordentlich in prekäre situation war
und das ist natürlich auch darauf ankam
sozusagen wirtschaftliche hilfe seitens
des westens zu bekommen denn putin heute
sagt der westen hat uns belogen hat uns
eiskalt betrogen ist das aus der luft
gegriffen aus ihrer meinung aber mir was
ich damit damit hat er unrecht
doch putin sicht der dinge hat auch
hierzulande unterstützer gregor gysi ist
der meinung mit genscher habe
deutschland nicht wort gehalten die nato
osterweiterung hätte verhindert werden
können um russland zu besänftigen
die aufnahme in der nato auf verlangt
immer einstimmigkeit das heißt in dem
moment das waren ja zwei aus minister wo
die usa und deutschland theoretisch
immer nein sagen gibt es keine aufnahme
insofern konnten sie das schon erklären
wenn sie es auch nur für zwei mitglieder
der nato erklären reicht das völlig aus
fakt aber ist vertraglich fixiert wurde
der genscher vorschlag nie
marie agnes strack zimmermann ist heute
fdp
verteidigungsexpertin wie interpretiert
sie die aussage des großen mannes ihrer
partei
sei nicht dass nicht die absicht besteht
das radio verteidigungs gebiet
auszudehnen nach osten vermutlich wollte
er sagen dass deutschland nicht proaktiv
auf diese länder zu geben sagt jetzt
kommt mal in die nato das war auch gar
nicht erforderlich diese länder haben
von sich aus angeklopft in der tat
treten schon 1999 polen tschechien und
ungarn der nato bei
polens damaliger präsident aleksander
kwasniewski erinnert sich 1999 führt er
sein land in die nato russland protest
zum trotz
jelzin hat immer versucht mir zu
erklären warum polen nicht in die nato
dürfe und ich habe ihn gefragt was habt
ihr für beziehungen zu den deutschen und
er sagte sehr guter und zu briten
franzosen und italienern auch gut und
jetzt sagst du mir mit und sei das nicht
möglich geld hin sagte nein ihr wollt
ihr an die nato na also sagte ich mit
allen nato-ländern hast du gute
beziehungen und ich verspreche dir dass
wir die auch haben wenn wir erst in der
nato sind da hat er gelacht und
verstanden dass seine argumentation
keinen sinn ergab
russland und der westen verhandeln mit
der nato russland akte sagt die allianz
zu dass in den neuen bündnis ländern
bäder atomwaffen noch kampftruppen
stationiert werden
präsident boris jelzin gibt damit grünes
licht zur osterweiterung mit gute miene
zum bösen spiel
2004 folgen sieben weitere
osteuropäische länder estland lettland
litauen die slowakei slowenien rumänien
und bulgarien
auf der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
2007 ist jelzins nachfolger das lachen
vergangen wladimir putin macht
unmissverständlich klar dass er die nato
osterweiterung als wortbruch an seinem
land versteht
was ist aus den erklärungen geworden die
von den westlichen partnern nach dem
zusammenbruch des warschauer paktes
gegeben wurden
trotzdem 2009 geht die erweiterung
weiter albanien und kroatien kommen dazu
2017 montenegro und 2020 nord mazedonien
als auch in der ukraine menschen
richtung westen und nato drängen kommt
es zum showdown
2014 annektiert putin die krim
völkerrechtswidrig und nimmt ein land in
geiselhaft für seine vorwürfe gegenüber
dem westen damit begeht er wortbruch
schließlich hat der kreml 1994
vertraglich zugesichert die grenzen der
ukraine anzuerkennen im gegenzug zum
freiwilligen abzug der aus sowjetzeiten
stationierten atomwaffen diesen vertrag
hat putin gebrochen und erzählt seine
geschichte von der angeblichen bedrohung
russlands durch die nato
[Musik]
putin hat keine angst vor der nato putin
hat angst vor der macht der freiheit vor
der generation die in der ukraine nach
westen schaut die ein anderes leben
wollen dafür hat er angst denn der muss
damit rechnen wenn die ukraine sich dem
westen komplett zuwendet geht es ihr
deutlich besser als den anderen ländern
die sozusagen noch im schatten russlands
leben und der größte albtraum für ihn
ist dass auch diese länder sich
plötzlich
richtung westen orientieren
so droht moskau all jenen die sich dem
besten zu wenden der wunsch der ukraine
nach nato-mitgliedschaft könnte dem land
zum verhängnis werden heute mittag
kündigt russland einen teilabzug seiner
truppen an der beginn einer lösung
das was man jetzt verhandeln könnte um
die lage zu deeskalieren
das wäre ein moratorium das für einen
festgelegten zeitraum die nato überhaupt
nicht erweitert wird
es gibt leise signale der hoffnung heute
aus moskau vielleicht haben hier zwei
einen anfang gefunden für einen weg der
europa weg führt von wortbruch von
schuldzuweisungen und von krieg
[Musik]